I imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired to go to work and come
home every single day fulfilled by the
work that they do my hope is that this
course takes us a little further down
that path if people learn there why it
makes them better qualified and more
importantly more confident to choose the
careers choose the jobs and find the
companies that create environments in
which they are more likely to be
inspired and feel fulfilled and that's
the goal the discovery of why was not an
academic exercise or commercial exercise
it was something deeply deeply personal
I had a small business and after a few
years had lost my passion for what I was
doing people gave me silly advice like
do what you love I was doing the same
thing I didn't love it anymore thanks to
the confluence of some events I
discovered this naturally occurring
pattern I knew what I did and I knew how
I did it but I couldn't tell you why and
I realized I had to answer that question
if I was gonna find that balance and so
I became obsessed with answering this
question why do I do what I do not only
did it restore my passion it restored it
to levels I'd never experienced before
and as we do when we discover something
beautiful we share it with the people we
love
and so I shared it with my friends and
my friends started making crazy life
changes and they invited me to share
with their friends and I would show up
at someone's apartment and literally
give a little talk about this discovery
I'd made and I would just get more and
more invitations and this thing just
sort of spread organically and its
really changed the course of my life and
changed the course of my career where
now I'm completely devoted to spreading
this idea and helping people either find
their passion or amplify it if they
already have it having a job we love is
a right and not a privilege it's not for
the chosen few and so my hope is to
share this idea with as many people as
possible so that indeed saying I love my
job becomes the standard and not the
exception I used to do the why
discoveries myself that's how it began I
would actually help my friends learn
there why I used to sit down with them
and go through this process it took
hours who had asked them all about their
life and try and see the patterns to try
and discern their why and it was great
and highly effective but I was the only
one doing it so I shared it with others
and there was a few of us doing it but
still
you know there was this desire to do it
with more people and so we took this
process that I used to do manually and
took everything that I learned and put
it in this online course but it's
basically the exact same thing I used to
do by myself so it's it's really fun to
see it come to life and of course the
best thing about the Y is that it's a
biological constant it has nothing to do
with what we do it's based on the
biology of how we make decisions and
what drives us and motivates us which
means that it doesn't matter whether
you're retired or whether you're a
student it doesn't matter what industry
you're in this course is designed to
help people understand what makes them
tick and what drives them what inspires
them and that's why I'm really proud of
this I mean this will give people
something to grasp onto and find
inspiration and fulfillment and in
everything they do hopefully for the
rest of their lives all you need to do
is have the will and the desire to want
to understand what drives and inspires
you and that's why we designed this
course it's designed for people to find
that thing to understand the thing that
gives them their true north and helps
them wake up every single morning
inspired and come home fulfilled I mean
who wouldn't want that